[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIC BAHNA: Hi, everybody.
Over the last two
days, you've heard
a lot about how
Compute Engine can
help your company, your
organization, meet your needs
and the needs of your
customers better.
Things like 64 core VMs,
the first public cloud
with Skylake, GA
support for SAP HANA,
and discounts on
discounts on discounts.
Have any of you heard those and
thought, what about control?
How am I going to take
advantage of all of this
that Compute Engine
and Google Cloud have
to offer without control?
How am I going to convince
people in my organization
that we have the control
we need to take advantage
of these capabilities?
If so, this is a
session for you.
I'm Eric Bahna, and
I'm a Product Manager
on Google Compute Engine.
And I'm going to share with you
best practices around identity
and access management
on Compute Engine.
It's an awfully wordy title
for a Friday lunch hour.
So how do we get
from here to here?
"Where Compute
Engine and BigQuery
give us the power we want, IAM
gives us the control we need."
That's from Alan Cawse,
who is the Executive Vice
President of Technical Services
at Geotab, a leading telematics
company.
They gather over 300
billion data points
annually from a fleet
of over 500,000 devices
in their customers'
cars and trucks.
And they use BigQuery
to help their customers
make better decisions
around fleet optimization
and fuel economy.
But like a lot of organizations,
they need that control.
As a quick show of
hands, how many folks
went to the IO 211
session yesterday,
getting total control
of your cloud resources?
OK.
About 15% of you.
So you can take a
quick 5- or 10-minute
nap during the first section.
No more than 10 minutes, please.
I'll go over cloud IAM
concepts, just so we all
have the same baseline.
Next, I'll go into specific
pieces of Compute Engine,
and how they work, and how
it affects your IAM strategy.
The bulk of our session
will be on implementing
industry standard best
practices on Compute Engine.
Then, we'll wrap up
with a summary and Q&A.
One other question.
Since we had moved the
sessions from 11:20 to noon,
how many folks have
already eat lunch?
All right.
That's about half of you.
So I've got my work
cut out for me to make
sure you don't fall asleep.
Unless you're in that 5-minute
group that went to IO 211,
feel free.
For the rest of you, there's
one extra item on the agenda.
Let's start at the beginning.
In this case, it's the beginning
of life for [? Louvre ?] one
of the beagles, who
belongs to an engineer who
brings you Compute Engine.
In this photo, he's
a few weeks old.
One of the things that struck
me when I joined the team
is how many people owned dogs.
I didn't think about this.
And I don't want to get into
the dogs versus cats debate.
I know that's a heated
issue for some folks,
but we have so many dog owners
in the Compute Engine and IAM
teams, they can guide
us through this session.
So we'll start at the beginning
with cloud IAM concepts.
IAM is about who can do
what on which resource.
Here are the different who's.
There are four types of
identities that you'll
be using in Google Cloud.
The first is a Google account.
This could be someone's
Gmail account.
It could be an account as
part of your G Suite domain.
These are accounts that
belong to human beings.
They can call APIs.
They can log in
interactively to the console.
The second type of identity
is a service account.
And this is the identity
that your code will be
running as on Compute Engine.
So for example, if you're using
Compute Engine and BigQuery
to do data analysis, you
could grant your code,
or the instance it runs
on, a service account.
And grant that service account
permission to the BigQuery data
that you need.
It's important to note
service accounts cannot log
in interactively to the console.
We still have a ways before
the robots take over.
The third identity
is a G Suite Domain.
This represents everyone
in your G Suite Domain
and is a way of sharing
your resource very broadly.
For example, if you wanted
to share a particular image
with everyone in
your organization,
you can grant a role
to the G Suite Domain.
And the fourth,
and the one we'll
be using most commonly for IAM
policies, is a Google group.
A group can have
any of these four--
a Google account,
service account,
or a G Suite Domain, or
another group inside of it.
So what happens now when
someone calls an API?
Let's say they're calling
the instances get method
on compute.
Well, in some cases,
Compute Engine
will ask one-to-one with IAM.
Compute instances
get is the method.
Compute instance get permission
is what we check for with IAM.
Other times, it's one-to-many.
If you try to create an
instance, we'll check,
do you have permission
to create the instance?
Do you have permission to use
the network that you're trying
to attach the instance to?
Do you have permission to use
the image that you specified?
So sometimes, one-to-one.
Sometimes, one-to-many.
Here's the what.
You can give these identities
permissions through IAM roles.
Now, roles are just
sets of permissions.
For example, if you
wanted to allow developers
in your organization to
create instances, and manage
them, and delete them, you could
grant them the instance admin
role.
It includes permissions to
start, stop, create, delete,
and manage instances.
You can grant these roles to
an identity, like a group,
on a resource such as a project.
There are three
types of IAM roles.
And the one to use depends
on your organization's needs.
First, a little bit of history.
When we started
with Compute Engine,
we started with three
broad primitive roles--
owner, editor, and viewer.
Now, these gave broad
access across services.
An editor could create an
instance on Compute Engine.
It could also create
a Cloud SQL instance.
Last year at Next,
we announced that we
had IAM roles to provide
more granular permission.
Today, we have over 70
predefined IAM roles.
You can use these
to grant an employee
access to specific
parts of Google Cloud.
For example, if you wanted
to allow your networking
and security team to
manage all the networks,
you could grant them the
compute network admin role.
That would not allow them
to spin up instances,
but they could do
network management,
create new networks,
subnets, and routes.
And the third, as we
announced yesterday,
is custom roles, which we
have available in alpha.
This allows you to
use which permission
you want to give someone.
If you only want them to call
three particular methods,
you could create that role.
You could create
them from scratch--
not recommended.
The best practice
would be to create them
from an existing role.
So if you have, for example,
an entitlement system
already on premises,
think about how
you want that
employee's access to map
to Google Cloud,
which methods you
want them to be able to call.
Find the predefined role that
most closely matches that,
and then add or remove
to get your custom role.
For example, if you
wanted to allow developers
to create instances, but
not modify the network
perimeter by assigning
an external IP address,
you could remove
that permission.
And the final concept around IAM
is that of resource hierarchy.
IAM is about who can do
what on which resource.
Here are the resources.
At the top, it's your
organization node,
which is tied to your domain.
And below that you can create
a folder for each division
or for each team.
And within those
folders, you could
create folders for
product or a project
for a particular service.
And then within that, specific
resources, like instances,
or subnets, or service accounts.
The project provides
the isolation
between different teams
and different services
in your organization.
So think of putting each
individual micro-service down
at the bottom of this
resource hierarchy.
We'll talk about that
more a little bit later.
OK.
So there's the summary
of IAM concept.
Now, we're off and running.
This is [? Louvre ?] again.
He's a little bit older,
a little bit wiser.
He knows a little bit about
Cloud IAM at this point.
Now we'll go into Compute
Engine, and a few specific ways
that it works, and how it
affects your IAM strategy.
First, if you're
thinking about security,
you're thinking about, what
are the bad outcomes that
are possible?
Not necessarily
fun to think about,
but important to think about.
And whenever you have
a machine, whether it's
a machine on premises,
a virtual machine,
or in the cloud, what would
happen if someone unauthorized
gained access to it?
So you want to provide
mechanisms such
that you can limit what
an instance can access
as a way of reducing risk.
Now, the first such mechanism
are OAuth access scopes.
This was in the
pre-IAM world, where
we had these three primitive
roles-- owner, editor,
and viewer.
And each project had
one service account
that all instances ran as.
Well, if you have
this one account that
has rather broad privilege,
you want some way
to be able to limit your
particular instance or instance
group to just what you need.
And access scopes
were a way to do that.
They're relatively broad
in their granularity.
For example, you could
give someone permission
to just the compute API
or the read-only methods
in the compute API.
Now, there was one special
scope, the Cloud platform
scope, which allowed access
to all of Google Cloud APIs.
We'll talk about that one
more a little bit later.
Now with IAM, you
could use IAM roles
as the mechanism to limit
what your instance can
access through an API.
We have over 70 such roles.
It offers a lot more flexibility
and granularity than scopes.
And instances today can each run
as their own service account.
So each component of your app
could have its own identity
and its own level of access to
the resources in your project
or in your organization.
And these roles,
as we saw earlier,
can be much more fine-grained
than these broader
access scopes.
One of the common
operations when
someone needs to
create an instance,
you want to go in and
see, what do you have?
Maybe you're going in to set
something up for the first time
or to troubleshoot an issue.
We wanted to make that
easy in Compute Engine.
So if you go to our web console
and you click the SSH button,
magic happens and in you are.
So what do we actually do?
And what's the impact on IAM?
When you click on
this SSH button,
we generate a new key pair.
And we'll send the
public key into the guest
using our metadata service.
That's a key value
pair data store.
Then we use the
corresponding private key
to start your session.
The reason why I
bring this up is
that identity and
access management is not
just about IAM roles.
Let's think about, what are all
of the identities, including
SSH keys, and what can
they access in the guest?
So there are two options there.
First is automatic
key management.
If people in your
organization will only
need SSH using either
the Google Web Console
or using the gcloud
command line tool,
you don't have to do anything.
We'll create the key pairs.
If necessary, we'll create a
new one if they've expired.
SSH just works.
On the other hand, a lot
of you have existing SSH
key management on premises.
So if you want to continue to
manually manage those SSH keys,
you could do that by setting
them on the SSH keys metadata
field, and that would
put the public keys
into your instances.
If you want to allow
all of your developers
to SSH into all the
VMs in your project,
you could set the public key
once on the project metadata
and it gets inherited
by all instances.
On the other hand, if
you wanted to allow
a contractor or a vendor
access to a specific instance
to troubleshoot an issue, you
could put their public key
on the instance metadata.
So there's two levels.
There's a resource
hierarchy there as well.
I should note that SSH is
a particularly powerful
permission to give someone.
First, anyone who
can SSH in by default
is also part of the
[INAUDIBLE] group.
But secondly, they
can also run commands
as that instance's
service account.
So there's a way for
someone to get access
to resources that you may
not have give them directly.
And I'll show you what
we did about that.
We treat a service account
both as an identity
and as a resource.
It's an identity in the
sense that if your code needs
to call BigQuery, you
could grant an IAM
role to your instance's service
account to access BigQuery.
It's a resource in
the sense that you
can grant users or
groups permission
to act as that service account.
And we wanted this to
be an explicit decision
that you make.
We don't want there to be
any elevation of privilege.
We want it to be
an explicit choice.
So here's what this
could look like.
Suppose we had a project where
a user is an instance admin.
They can create and
delete instances.
This is the sign for creating
and deleting instances,
by the way.
And then, you give the service
account access to BigQuery
so it can run queries, create
saved queries, write new data.
If we didn't treat the
service account as a resource,
here's what could happen.
You could have the
user trying to get
a data set from BigQuery.
BigQuery would check
with Cloud IAM.
IAM would check
against the IAM policy.
It would actually check against
all policies in the hierarchy.
IAM would rightly say no and
BigQuery would rightly say no.
So far, so good.
Now, suppose that
this instance admin
creates an instance and
Compute Engine checks with IAM.
Oh, you have permission
to create instances.
You have permission
to create disks.
Here's your instance running
as a service account.
And now that user could SSH in
and use the service account's
credential to access that data
in BigQuery that we didn't
want them to have access to.
That's not what we want.
Instead, we want it to
be an explicit choice.
So if someone does
not have permission
to act as that service account
which you've given them,
then this would happen.
BigQuery, again, will
say no, as it should.
But when they ask Compute Engine
to create an instance that
runs at that service
account, we will also check,
do you have permission to
act as the service account?
IAM will say no.
We'll say no.
No elevation of privilege.
We wanted to avoid surprises.
If you want someone to
act as another identity,
it's an explicit
choice that you make.
Service account actor role
is the predefined role
that grants this
"act as" permission.
And Compute Engine checks for
this permission in two cases.
First is if the API would
cause different code
to run inside the guest.
For example, if you're setting
a startup script or a shutdown
script.
We will check you
have permission
not only to set that metadata,
but you have permission
to act as that service account.
And similarly, if you're
going to change the service
account that the
instance runs as,
do you have permission to act
as that new service account?
All right.
That's the background.
We've covered the IAM
concepts, a little bit
about Compute Engine.
Now we're onto identity
best practices.
Identity here embodied by Milo,
who is a chihuahua-rat terrier
mix, or a spider at Google scale
depending on who you believe.
The first best practice is to
reuse your existing identities.
How many of you have
an on-premises LDAP
server right now?
OK.
That's about 3/4 of you.
If you have an on-premises LDAP
server, like Active Directory,
you can install the Google
Cloud Directory Sync
tool, a free download, to
sync one way users and groups
from your LDAP
server into G Suite.
So you can continue managing
users and groups the way
you always have been and now be
able to grant them permission
to cloud resources.
The second best
practice around identity
is to not store keys or
secrets in your code.
You've probably
heard news stories
about people scanning
GitHub looking for API keys,
or heard about the Truffle Hog
project to help you find them.
We wanted to make
it easy to make sure
that you don't have to
manage keys or access
tokens in most cases.
If your code is running
on Compute Engine
and you need to call
another Google API,
like BigQuery, just install the
client library for the language
that you need.
Python client library, for
example, and things just work.
You don't have to
get an access token.
You don't have to create a key
pair for the service account.
You just call the
API and it works.
If you're doing
local development,
you can download the same
client library to your laptop.
You can create a new key pair
for that service account.
And then set the Google
application credentials
environment variable to
the path to that key.
You don't have to put
it into your code,
and then the calls just work.
We want it to be
easy that you can not
have to manage tokens and keys.
The next identity
best practice--
because again, identity is more
than just about IAM roles--
is requiring more
secure authentication.
You have heard the
identity as a service talk.
And in there, a lot
of folks mentioned
how they were already using
two-factor auth, which
is awesome.
And we also announced security
keys, a more phishing-resistant
token that you can use to
identify a particular user.
And you can enable this
on your G Suite Domain
just by going into
the Admin Console
and clicking the radio button.
The second set of identities
to think about then
are people who can SSH
in to your instances.
First, we recommend disabling
password authentication
because key pairs are
a more secure way.
And secondly,
disable root login.
So if someone has to
run an elevated command,
you have a better chance at
finding that in the auth log
afterwards.
Compute Engine images
already do these.
There are a lot of
other best practices
around image management that
I couldn't do justice to here.
So there's a doc for
more information.
That brings us to
least privilege.
[? Dico ?] is a
bullmastiff and boxer
who embodies least privilege.
Good luck getting through.
There's two chairs and there's
[? Dico ?] in the middle.
So the first best practice
around this on Compute Engine
is obviously granting
predefined or custom roles--
usually.
Depending on how you've set
up your resource hierarchy,
there may be times where
you could give someone
like your networking team the
owner role on a project that
only has networking resources.
We'll talk about that
more in a few minutes.
There are some
operations that are
particularly powerful that
you want to be aware of.
The first is setting
an IAM policy.
Someone who can
set an IAM policy
could grant
themselves or someone
else any role on that resource.
So by default, the owner
and the organization admins
are the two roles that
have that permission.
The second powerful operation
is acting as a service account,
as we talked about
a bit earlier.
Because if you can
access a service account,
you can now get access to
data that that service account
has access to.
You can do things
like set metadata
to modify startup
and shutdown scripts.
And there are three roles that
have that-- owner, editor,
and service account actor.
The best practice
on compute is then
that you give the service
account active role,
that permission to act
as a service account,
you grant that on a
particular service account
rather than on the project.
If you grant it on
the project, the group
that you gave access to can
now access all of the service
accounts in your
project, including
those they may have
nothing to do with.
There's one exception.
If you want someone to be able
to set project-level metadata,
if you want someone to be
able to set a common startup
script for all instances
in your project,
give them the service account
actor role on the project.
And the reason for that is that
if you set project metadata,
we don't want to just check,
do you have permission
to all the existing instances.
Although, that
startup script will
affect all existing instances.
They'll also affect
all instances
you create in the future.
And that's why we want to
check for that permission
at the project
level and not just
on each individual instance.
Anytime we talk about
best practices around IAM,
we're sort of duty bound to
mention use groups, not users.
I won't belabor this point.
I will say one thing if you're
managing groups in G Suite,
not on your on-premises server,
then that's in the Admin
Console, admin.google.com.
Separate from the
IAM policies you'll
be setting in the Cloud console.
That's all I'm going
to say about groups.
So I've talked a little bit
about least privilege to users.
Also, least privilege is
necessary for applications.
Suppose that you have a
content streaming company.
And you want to
both stream content
and also do some data analytics.
Maybe understand which
next piece of content
to recommend, which ad to serve
up, how to increase conversion.
The best practice
here is that you
give each instance
or group of instances
their own service account.
In this case, the content
streaming instances
have one identity, the content
stream or service account.
And the instance you're
using for data analysis
have the data analyzer
service account.
You could grant each of
those service accounts
just the IAM roles
on just the resources
that they each need
to do their jobs.
But then, give each
of these instances
a very permissive scope.
Remember, we talked about
scopes and IAM roles earlier.
It seems a little
odd that we would
say in a least privilege
section of a session grant
very permissive scopes.
Here's why that's
going to be OK.
When your instance is
making an API request,
there are two mechanisms
of authorization
that it has to pass.
So when this VM is
querying BigQuery,
we automatically-- because
you're running inside
of Compute Engine,
we automatically
get the access token.
That access token
includes both the identity
of the service account as well
as a set of access scopes.
What BigQuery will
then do is first check,
is this set of
scopes something that
allows this API to be called?
And if so, then go
and ask Cloud IAM,
do you have-- does this
service account have access
to this resource?
Because you have Cloud IAM as
the definitive authorization
store for Google
Cloud platform, you
could leave the
scopes wide open.
That makes it easier to
configure your instances,
but doesn't leave you in
any more of a risky state.
Because even if someone
has wide open scopes,
IAM is still the
definitive answer
as to whether they
can access a resource.
I'd also be remiss if I
didn't mention key rotation.
And there are two sets
of keys that you'd
be interested in here.
One is keys for the
service account.
For example, if you're
querying a service
outside of Google Cloud, you
need to export your own service
keys.
You can do key rotation
by creating a new key
with the create API, replace
the old one with a new one,
and then delete the old one.
Public keys for SSH are
treated a little differently
in that instance
metadata is written
in a read/modify/write paradigm.
So add the new key,
set the metadata,
do the key replacement,
and then remove the key
by setting metadata again.
For similar reasons
that you don't
want to store secrets
or keys in code,
so, too, in instance metadata.
The purpose of the
metadata service
is to provide configuration
information between the Google
cloud APIs and your instances.
So things like startup scripts,
shutdown scripts, public SSH
keys.
If this metadata is treated as
part of the instance resource.
So anyone who can
get an instance
will be able to see all of
the metadata on that instance.
So if, for example, your
instances use a private token
to access a service that
you're managing yourself,
store that token
or that password
or that key in Cloud
Storage and then
give access to the
instance's service
account to read the information.
That way, anyone who lists
the instance won't see it,
but your instance will
still have access to it.
That brings us to the third
section, centralized control.
Embodied here by Kira, a
Klee Kai who has centralized
control of this couch and
also part of the fireplace.
The first best practice
around centralized control
is to bring your organization's
existing structure
to the cloud.
If you have, for example,
a lot of developers
who are allowed to create
cloud projects, what
happens if one of
those developers
leaves the company and those
resources are still going?
With the organization node,
anyone who creates a project,
if their email address
is part of your domain,
that's automatically part
of the organization node.
And therefore, your
organization admins
can set policies to allow a
particular group of individuals
to gain access to them
in case, for example,
the project owner leaves.
You could also then take
advantage of organization
policies that my
colleagues Ray and Ray
discussed yesterday in IO 211
to set the ground rules for what
people are allowed to do
within the organization,
even if they have relative
autonomy within their project.
The best practices
here are first,
use the org node for
centralized control.
Map your company's domain
to your organization node,
and then create folders
for divisions or teams.
Projects for each service,
for each environment.
So you have one project for
a team's dev environment,
test environment,
and prod environment.
That way, you can
give stricter control
over that prod environment
while allowing developers more
freedom in dev and in test.
A lot of organizations have
standardized IT blessed images
and want to make
it easier for you
to share those images with
people in your organization
so it's easy for them
to create the instance
that you want them to.
The best practices
here are first,
start with Google-provided
images as your base.
We make optimizations
in these images
to run them on Compute
Engine, and include
already a lot of
the best practices
around image management, some
of which I alluded to earlier.
The second best practice is to
publish your approved images
to a shared project
and make those
available to the
developers that need it.
I'll show you an
example in a moment.
And the third best
practice to be mindful of
is when you're testing
these images before they
have been approved, do that
testing in a separate project,
not in the shared
images project.
You don't want someone getting
a sneak peek at the next round
of images before it's ready.
So here's what this
could look like.
Suppose you want to give your
data scientists permission
to create, update,
and delete instances,
but you want them to
use your blessed images,
the ones created
by your IT staff.
So you could first create
a data analysis project,
give the data scientist
group the instance admin role
in that project.
Now they can create
and delete instances.
And then, have a separate
shared images project
where your IT staff
has the instance admin
role, so they can create
instances, delete them, create
images and delete them.
And then give the
image user role
to the data scientist group.
So now as your IT staff
publishes approved images,
the data scientists
just get access to them.
They don't need to create
their own copy of them.
They don't have to download
them into their own project.
Now suddenly, you have
this proliferation.
They can just use them directly
from the shared images project.
Similarly for
controlling networks,
a lot of organizations
have a security team
that wants to have control
over all network traffic.
You want to make sure that
you're routing traffic
through a particular set of
firewall rules, or proxies.
So we make that
easy in two ways.
One, if you're already a Compute
Engine customer before we
announced cross-project
networking during the VPC
session here, you may have a
number of different projects
that already have networks
or subnets in them.
You could give developers
the instance admin
role on that project, so
they can't monkey around
with the firewalls,
the networking,
and give your network and
security team the network admin
and security admin
roles on those projects.
If you're starting
something new,
you have an even
more flexible option
available with
cross-project networking.
And the recommendation there
is that you create one XPN
host per network
that you're sharing,
and then grant the
networking team
the owner role on that project.
This is one of those
exceptions where
you don't have to grant
them a very narrow role
because that project is only
for networking resources.
And the networking
team can grant access
to other groups on
specific subnets.
So this means that
the data scientists
can have easy communication
between all of their instances
while still
maintaining isolation
from other services
and other teams.
So your policies
might look like this.
In this case, we granted
the network user role
to the data scientist
just on a specific subnet.
And the last best
practice, this is
like the opposite of camping.
You very much want
to leave a trace.
And even during this conference,
we got a reminder as to why.
When Columbia Sportswear,
according to "The Seattle
Times" sued a former
employee, who allegedly,
on their last day of work, had
created a new user account,
granted broad access
to that user account,
and then used it after
they left the company
to access internal information.
The best practices in
this case on compute--
and some of these apply to
Google Cloud more broadly--
first is retain audit
logs in accordance
with your business's risks
and mitigation strategies.
The length of time that you
would maintain these logs
depends on what risks you're
trying to protect against.
And also, how many resources
you have to go and look
into all this data afterwards.
In Google Cloud,
you can set up logs
to be exported to Cloud Storage
or to BigQuery for easier data
analysis.
You can also have been them
set up to be sent via Pub/Subs.
You can respond
in near real time
if something suspicious happens,
like someone setting an IAM
policy that you don't like.
There are other
organizations that
need to also manage and monitor
what happens inside the guest.
For example, if
you need to monder
the SSHD logs to
see who's trying
to access your instances,
you could set up
the Stackdriver logging agent
to forward those events from all
of your instances
to a central place,
and then you can look
for trends in who's
trying to get into
your instances there.
All right.
Now is the demo section.
Before we switch over, the
demo, unlike most sections,
is embodied by two of
our team's dogs, not one.
First is [? Kopi. ?]
[? Kopi's ?] a poodle,
very playful.
We're going to go play
around now in Compute Engine.
That is a relatively
optimistic view of the demo.
And Noodles embodies
another view,
depending on how the demo goes.
Also a chihuahua-terrier mix.
All right.
Can we switch over
to the demo, please?
OK.
So what we're looking at here is
an organization that I created.
And we have a few
different departments.
We have data
science, engineering,
and shared resources.
These are all folders in
the resource hierarchy.
And we have here the
data science dev project.
We can examine the
IAM policy there.
What you'll see is that we
granted the compute instance
admin role to the
data scientist group.
So they'll be able to create
and manage instances here.
We also want those
same data scientists
to have access to
the shared images.
So if we look at
the images project,
you'll see that we granted
the compute image user
role to that same group.
And additionally,
because we want
to maintain more control over
our networking and our firewall
rules, we give them access to
a shared network in the XPN dev
project.
And here they are,
that same group.
Finally, because
they're data scientists,
and data is one of their
favorite four-letter words,
we're also granting them
the BigQuery data viewer
role and the BigQuery user
role on our org data project.
So they can access
all of this data.
I'll show you one
other resource.
Since we talked about
controlling permissions
to APIs that your
instances are calling,
let's look at the data
science dev project.
And we'll check the
service accounts there.
There are two service accounts.
One that Compute Engine
creates by default,
and then I created this data
analyzer service account.
And this as well you
can set permissions on.
And you can see that data
scientists have the service
account actor role just
on that service account,
not on any other
in that project.
So this now allows them
to create instances
that run as this service account
to query that BigQuery data.
OK.
Now, I'm going to login as
one of the data scientists.
It's a very secretive company,
so her last name is redacted.
All right.
Now, we are looking at this from
Alice's point of view, who's
a member of the data
scientist group.
So she has access to the
data science dev project.
She could create
instances there.
Let's see if she just tried
to snoop around a bit.
So you can see
that in this case,
Alice and no data
scientists has access
to view the IAM policies
for this project,
but they do have access to
some of the other resources,
like Compute Engine.
Let's go and create an instance.
We'll put it here in US Central.
So the first thing is, which
image are we going to use?
There are the
Google-provided images.
There's a variety of OSes there,
including Windows as well.
We're going to go
over to Custom Images.
And we can choose
to look at custom
images in these projects.
There's none in
data science dev.
But if you look at
the images project,
there we have our
custom Ubuntu V2 image.
That's the latest one
that's been approved,
so we'll use that one.
Now we have our choice
of service accounts.
We'll choose the Data
Analyzer service account.
And note that when you choose
one other than the default,
we set the Cloud platform
scope for you automatically.
Which means you just need
to think about the IAM roles
and not about access
scopes to make sure
that the instance and your
code has access to the APIs
you need.
And for the last piece, we
will use a shared network.
You see we have
the XPN dev network
that we've shared subnets from.
And we can connect to that.
So now we'll create
our instance using
shared image, shared subnet,
and using only the service
account that Alice and the other
data scientists have access to.
All right.
So now, let's SSH in there.
And you'll see we're going
to transfer the SSH key.
This says generating
a new key pair,
sending the public
key into the instance,
and then using the private
key to setup the session.
All right.
Now, just to show
you how easy it
is if you're using the
client libraries to access
the data that you
need in Google Cloud
from within a
virtual machine, I'm
going to install the client
library for BigQuery.
OK.
So here is the
quick Python script.
We import the client library,
instantiate the client.
And then we just
call, in this case,
the list data sets method.
And it will also list all the
tables within each data set.
Important to note
what's not done here
is specifying a credential,
downloading a key,
querying for an access token.
And there are the
logs from the org data
project, the one that
this service account has
been granted access to.
And the different
tables in those logs.
These are all audit
logs from today.
So now let me switch over.
We'll go to BigQuery.
Note, by the way, that when I
switched over to the org data
project, because we had started
in the Compute Engine view,
the console shows the same
view in the new project.
And Alice, rightly, does not
have access to view instances
or do any instance-level
operations in this project.
Now, let's go over to BigQuery.
OK.
And now, I'm just
going to show what's
some of the activity that
happened in this project today.
And you can see we're looking
at this by the newest first.
And so a bunch of the
operation that we've
been doing throughout the
demo you can see here,
Alice is the one who's
been running them.
And then, here are the different
methods that have been called.
Creating instances,
setting metadata,
to set those public keys.
All right.
Can we switch back to
the slides, please?
It turns out, we didn't
need Noodles after all.
Nothing crashed.
So in summary, we started
with the IAM concepts--
review for some of
you, new for others.
And then, talked about
how specific parts
of Compute Engine work and how
it affects your IAM strategy.
The relationship between
scopes and IAM roles.
SSH keys and the
metadata server.
And the service account
actor and why it's important
that that's an explicit
decision and not something
you want to be surprised by.
Then, I shared best practices
in these three areas
around identity,
least privilege,
and centralized control.
These were the best
practices around identity
and how to implement
those on Compute Engine.
Some of these are
general for Google Cloud
overall, such as
syncing your identities.
Similarly, the best prices that
I showed for least privilege.
I should have had a picture
of [? Dico ?] on here, too.
But there's no space.
That dog is huge and there's
a lot of best practices.
And then, best practices
around centralized control.
In particular, around using the
organization node and resource
hierarchy.
Here are some of
the capabilities
that I talked about and links to
read more about each of those.
Things like IAM roles,
service accounts,
Google Cloud directory sync.
Just going to wait because I
see there was still some cameras
up.
And then, additional resources.
We have an extensive
document on best practices
for enterprise organizations.
As well as on best practices
around image management
and securing your images.
There were three other
sessions at Next this year
that are related to this area.
All of them have
already happened,
but you can find
them on YouTube.
They're already on YouTube.
One of those is BP203,
Identity as a Service.
IO211, Gaining Full Control.
And then, Virtual
Private Clouds, IO401.
And with that, hopefully we
can all rest as easily as Milo
here, because we know
the best practices
for securing your workloads on
Compute Engine in Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]